transverses une quantité record à la
récupère une partie mais la fin la pac
est majoritairement financée par des
fonds qui viennent pas de fin ce qui
l'est ce qui n'est pas normal
l'europe impose une augmentation
constante de la productivité elle coûte
plus qu'elle ne rapporte et impose la
sueur industrialisation et panis le bio
nous dit alex on va passer un dernier un
avant dernier un sujet qui est important
là on va quitter les campagnes on va
aller dans les banlieues on vous pose
une question selon vous la situation est
elle aussi grave que celle décrite par
valérie pécresse dans son interview au
figaro ou le multiplie les phrases chocs
et les chiffres chocs je suis une
femelle blanche et je revendique le
droit d'apporter des solutions à nos
quartiers nous dit la présidente
heller d'île de france 90 est attaqué en
décembre d enseigner resperger d'essence
270 quartiers sensibles délinquance
communautarisme voici donc quelques
illustrations selon valérie pécresse
d'un phénomène
selon elle il suffit d'une étincelle et
nous revivrons les émeutes de 2005
est-ce que ce constat est exagéré est ce
qu'il est intéressé qu'il faut rendre
crédit
valérie pécresse de comment dire d'un
côté nous avons un mauvais théâtre qui
est le théâtre d gilet jaune un théâtre
des meutes de violences de dégradations
de on en est à l'acte 15 auquel répond
une forme de théâtre présidentielle le
le grand débat les implications du
président devant des espèces de grandes
performances théâtrales devant 600 800
mère est comme une espèce de double jeu
d'illusions on voit le les sondages
présidentiels remonter on voit le le
soutien au gilet jaune diminué mais est
à côté il ya la réalité la réalité des
cités des quartiers la réalité du pays
dans ces démocraties en croissance que
d'écrire valérie pécresse et je crois
que non seulement elle n'exagère pas
mais elle nous rappelle une chose c'est
que en fait on a eu de la chance on a de
la chance c'est à dire au moment de ces
mauvaises ces mauvais théâtre des gilet
jaune ou qui absorbé l'essentiel de nos
forces de l'ordre eh bien nous avons des
quartiers des banlieues qui dieu merci
n'ont pas flambé
ça s'est passé
dieu merci mon peu fort mais nous avons
eu de la chance elle cite notamment ce
lycéen qui était touché par un
flash-ball québec 45 minutes dans le
coma je vais au bout du raisonnement
donc elle dit attention à côté du
mauvais théâtre qui se déroule il y à
une bombe qui continuent d'être à
retardement et il ne faut pas grand
chose pour la pour l'enclencher ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette dans cette
interview c'est qu'elle elle tape dans
le dur et l indique
attention il ya des mairies de gauche
qui se satisfont tout à fait de
l'optique de ghettoïsation qui
fonctionne pour elle c'est à dire on
ghettoïse socialement pour continuer de
se faire élire et réélire et on est allé
de quelques accalmies réel par les
quelques mairies chacal en cite quelques
unes dans son papier de seine de seine
saint denis
elle rappelle une élisant des mairies ou
et des communes où il y à plus de 30 %
de logements sociaux voilà n'ai pas vu
qu'elle citait à la crise et à la nasa
elle rappelle elle rappelait plus de 60
pour les plus de 60 ans elle dit qu'il
faut descendre à 30 % de logements
sociaux
elle rappelle une évidence et que nous
avons fait l'impasse sur le plan
banlieue de jean louis borloo
mais au bout du raisonnement est que sur
le plan banlieue de jean louis borloo
certes qui étaient perfectibles on ne
travaille pas tout avec l'argent mais on
va revenir sur sur jean louis borloo
normes et j'entends votre raisonnement
en lisant je voudrais leur juste parce
que vous avez fait votre raisonnement il
en deux temps il ya un premier temps
s'est dit vous avez dit tout à l'heure
heureusement qu' il n'y a pas eu
justement de soulèvements banlieue je
propose d'écouter peut-être julien dray
sur cette question là et après on on y
revient lamont du raval là quand vous
expliquer qu'elle n'est pas présente
normes beaucoup dans le débat et gilet
jaune mais pour une raison simple c'est
qu'on a laissé dans les banlieues
s'installer un trafic de stupéfiants
gigantesque way de mafia qui exerce une
sorte de conte dérangerait si on avait
beaucoup de beaucoup de ceux qui
organisent le trafic ne veulent pas
qu'on les aime et qu'on les dérange donc
ils veulent pas qu'on dise les banlieues
sont allés il ya eu au début un petit
peu des manifestations quelques bandes
qui sont venus
piller et qui se sont abstenus devenir
d'abord parce qu'elle était vite repéré
les deux héros parce qu'il ya une prise
en main une tenue dans ces quartiers là
c'est sa team c'est ça qui m'angoisse et
qu'on a laissé faire je dirais voilà la
situation s'accommode de cette situation
fait vieux il ya mieux
quel discours de départ de gérard
collomb du ministère de l'intérieur
il l'a dit noir sur blanc et il a même
laissé comprendre il a dit ensuite que
c'était une des causes de rupture avec
edouard philippe emmanuel macron la
ferme et dallas est une chose il y avait
des choses urgentes à régler dans les
banlieues qui sont en train de dépérir
et qui sont en train de se reconstituer
comme un volcan qui va péter encore plus
fort que le gilet jaune
il a voulu intervenir là dedans et on
l'a dit on lui a dit non comme on dit
tous les autres gouvernements
donc un jour effectivement mais c'est à
se demander si quelque part le pouvoir
politique ne se satisfait pas de ces
fractures parce que c'est vrai que ça
consolide le pouvoir en place
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on attend les
gilet jaune là les abrutis qui
manifestent c'est la partie sans culotte
de la révolution française
à l'arrivée nous on a beau jeu de dire
voilà c'est ça les gilet jaune non
légine et jolie son entrée chez eux
c'est fini ce qui reste là c'est la
partie sans culotte c'est à dire les
fous les extrémistes voilà les très
violents que périco légasse travail dans
un genre il s'appelle maria oui pour la
prise de la bastille c'est pas les sans
culottes et ensuite on a eu des sans
culottes qui ont terrorisé sur lequel on
lui expliquait qu'on respire et
saint-just avait établi la république
pour soyons très prudent avec des gens
revenir sur la violence non mais c'est
parce que je veux pas faire d'amalgamé
il ya une fracture sociale avec les
gilet jaune qu'est ce qu'on fait on
ouvre dix milliards et puis on dit on va
on va saupoudré mais on aurait on ne
résout pas les causes hélas cali valérie
pécresse tout le monde le sait en haut
lieu depuis longtemps tous les ministres
de l'intérieur
on a eu une épreuve déjà 2005 ça va
revenir
et puis y aura un pouvoir fort qu'il
dira je rétablis l'or et puis qui sans
ce qui s'en tire en rétablissant l'ordre
non mais on prendra pas de mesures pour
faire en sorte que le drame des
banlieues soit effacée puisque on veut
pas mettre d'argent mais ce qui est
intéressant ce qu'est la différence de
l'essentiel du débat politique est
aujourd'hui capter sur un peu d'aidé mis
des représentations autour du gilet
jaune
elle propose des solutions des socios
concret là une stratégie de repeuplement
et elle propose comment est ce qu'on
fait les mixités avec les logements
sociaux
l or elle n'a pas cité jean-françois
copé mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
de voir qu'il ya des villes qui était
perdu d'avancé en terme de
de densité de logements sociaux de
communautarisme de ghettoïsation et avec
de la volonté avec des caméras de
surveillance des choses très concrètes
incite le chiffre de 3000 caméras de
surveillance en ile de france
eh bien vous arrivez à nettoyer des
quartiers a fait revenir les classes
moyennes en fait ça passe par une
stratégie de peuplement de sécurité
voilà le sait la droite des solutions et
par rapport à ce qui ressemble de plus
en plus effectivement une forme de
mauvais théâtre que qui est celui du
pouvoir aujourd'hui olivier il y a
également dans l'interview de l'île de
valérie pécresse qui dès que elle elle
veut qu'on revienne aux plans que
proposer jean louis borloo c'est une
bonne idée
à votre avis moi je ne sais pas besoin
de réclamer des quatre heures au moins
après 200 milliards qui ont été nourris
les banlieues de puissance un peu c'est
un peu contre nous et puis qui ont été
dépensés sans qu' il ya des endroits où
ça améliorer les choses mais qui
franchement elle le dit d'ailleurs
elle-même de le bilan de l'indh rue et
au moins contrasté puisque c'est aussi
du ripolinage qui a pas changé grand
chose et il faudrait que ce soit
accompagnée de quelle mesure de quelles
mesures de financement parce qu'on pas
la foi demande et la baisse des dépenses
publiques et dire il fallait prendre le
plan borloo qui coûtait 10 fois plus
cher
non ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'elle
fait des propositions qui sont assez
audacieuse pour moi elles sont bien dans
laquelle vous plaît en droit avec son
gauche mais ça veut pas dire grand chose
de drôle avec laquelle la plus
intéressante mais la plus compliquée
c'est la lutte contre la ghettoïsation
c'est donc quand elle dit il devrait pas
y avoir plus de 30 % de logements
sociaux mais elle fit un maximum et elle
ne re définit pas le minimum
le problème c'est très gentil de dire ça
mais les là où il n'y a pas de logement
ou très peu de logements sociaux ni la
population et les maires nous envie
qu'on fasse de la mixité et n'ont envie
qu'on augmente le pourcentage de
logements sociaux et donc c'est pas ce
pas que des méchants maires de gauche
qui ont voulu se mettre les clientèles
électorales et qui sont dits chic chic
on va faire du social comme ça va se
faire élire en plus de les catégories
populaires ne vote plus tellement pour
la gauche donc en plus de cet idiot
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
donc c'est assez courageux de dire que
le fond du problème est là
et qu'il faut pas beaucoup d'outils
introduire la mixité maintenant ça c'est
tout sauf facile parce que ça coûte de
l'argent
les populations y sont hostiles et la
plupart des élus y sont hostiles
dansant dans le film de kassovitz suffit
pas il a 20 ans 25 ans la haine leur
faim était jusqu'ici tout va bien
bon c'était prophétique c'est à dire que
les banlieues françaises sont le lieu de
toutes les inquiétudes des ministres de
l'intérieur qui qui se sont succédé
alors il ya la dimension matérielle dont
on parlait du plan borloo mais il ya une
dimension évidemment il matériel
là-dedans qui participe de ce que jérôme
fourquet dans le livre qu'il s'apprête à
publier appel l'archipel français c'est
à dire qu'il ya maintenant plusieurs
france christophe guilluy disait qu'un
parisien se sentait plus proche d'un
londonien que d'un français de la creuse
mais on pourrait dire parfois qu'un
jeune de banlieue se sent plus éloignés
d'un parisien ou que d'un français de la
creuse que de quelqu'un qui aurait la
même culture que lui d'un à des milliers
de kilomètres donc on est on est dans un
an on est on est on est devant une
situation qui est qui et qui est
politiquement explosive et qui implique
une équité matériel mais qui implique
aussi une dimension immatérielle et
culturelles pour dire les mots pour
rappeler aux gens qui vivent sur ce
territoire qu'il participe d'une
histoire commune et d'un destin commun
ilan héritage commun parce que sinon on
pourra mettre tout l'argent qu'on veut
partout on veut ça sera pas suffisant il
faut pas avoir le courage d'aller aussi
sur des mesures radicales
alors là c'est parce qu'elle dit il faut
réduire l'émigration et instaurer des
quotas est donc revenir au plan
juridique et dit que c'est pas les mêmes
la citation exacte et dit stop à
l'immigration ne réglera pas les
problèmes actuels des bonheurs que j'ai
lu oui c'est vrai mais ça c'est après on
le figaro ce précieux pour réduire
l'immigration a assuré des quotas quand
on parle du trafic de drogue est bidon
de l'incapacité à l'éradiquer est ce que
un des bons moyens n'est pas même si en
soi sasha grey a dit d'aller jusqu'à la
légalisation phénomène très français un
mot tout était écrit dans les
territoires perdus de la république qui
se sont fait lyncher insulté par la
bien-pensance alors ses lives de georges
bensoussan est paru en 2002 il nous
reste cinq minutes je voudrais d'abord
vous donner le résultat de réponses sûr
twitter la question selon vous la
situation dans les banlieues est elle
aussi grave que celle décrite par
valérie pécresse consommateurs pour et
non 28 % bravo bonne réponse de olivier
duhamel qui est le meilleur
pronostiqueur de l'émission point de vue
philippe à paris oui la situation est
gravissime et la reine ne souhaite pas
remettre par l'enjeu donne la parole aux
internautes ne souhaite pas remettre le
sujet du communautarisme dans le débat
peu de temps avant les élections
le gouvernement craint par dessus tout
la jonction gilet jaune banlieue estime
cm
le commentaire nous dit le clientélisme
politique est il la cause de ce état des
lieux désastreux malgré les millions
investis en tous les cas c'est la vie de
valérie pécresse
il y a des problèmes il y à des
problématiques mais le discours de
pécresse est anxiogène et stéréotypé
nous dit monsieur babineau il n'y a pas
que des mauvaises s p le commentaire
quelles seraient les solutions réalistes
à court terme en eau bien envie d'en
parler
nos politiques paieront un jour les
responsabilités et l'incompétence donc
ils ont toujours fait preuve en matière
d'immigration estime pragma il y à une
autre question il nous reste quatre
minutes mais je voulais
vous la poser c on va traverser la
manche
faut-il un second référendum en
grande-bretagne
c'est la question qu'on se pose depuis
une déclaration du chef du parti
travailliste jeremy corbyn faut dire que
ça faisait quelques années qu'on ne
savait pas qu'elle était la vraie
position de jérémy corps been sur ces
questions le britannique s'est moqué de
lui d'ailleurs au moment du bric site
nous nous engageons également à
présenter ou à soutenir un amendement en
faveur d'une consultation publique afin
d'empêcher que les conservateurs à
posent au pays